dean graziosi just responded to us
kind of he pulled a sneaky sneaky move
and i want to take this video i'm going
to make it quick okay but i want to call
it out as it's happening
because my advantage when dealing with
these people is that i know their tricks
i know the way they operate they're the
dark arts
i know them i don't use them but i know
them and i'm willing to call them out
for your benefit
lest you be tricked unless you be
deceived by their false humility
their fake vulnerability and their
forced positivity that's what we're
gonna talk about today but first
let's talk about him addressing us now
there was this instagram story that he
made that i was pretty sure was talking
about us
when someone alters the facts and talks
[ __ ]
it's brutal you guys feel the same way
dm me if you feel the same way and yeah
of course that was about us it was at
least the same day as my video but
ultimately what am i what am i
misrepresenting i i read off a court
case
i mean i was just reading the ftc i
could have done that
just straight off i was trying to make
it entertaining as well but ultimately
that was the substance of the argument
was hey
you've got an ftc case on your hands
buddy so i wasn't going to say anything
but today i got a tweet from a man
named jason owens bro did dean graziosi
lowkey
respond to you i was like uh i don't
think so i hadn't seen it so i go to his
youtube page
i see this the secret to finding a real
mentor exposed now
look at that thumbnail for a second
already i'm sus you know
online gurus exposed let's look into it
so i go to this page
and they're talking about finding a
mentor
but then i see in the description fake
gurus that's what i talk about all the
time
i see fake gurus and so i think surely
he's talking about me he's talking about
my video he's debunking me he's proving
me wrong
surely he's addressing it because
basically the ftc added
him to a gigantic 400 million dollar
real estate scam case and i talked about
it in my video and so maybe he's adding
some context but then i watched the
video
and no he did none of that they don't
mention us at all they don't mention
uh the ftc's allegations they don't
mention the case they don't mention
anything about dean
being in deep deep trouble and yet in
the description you see
fake guru mentioned several times in the
tags you see dean graziosi
tony robbins scam exposed ftc
fraud insider's edge nudge being
graziosi exposed how to find a mentor
mentor mentorship
fake gurus so he's
trying to keyword his way to the top
of the search result when you look up
dean graziosi's scam
but he actually isn't addressing it at
all it's just some random video
that he tagged with these things in fact
the one part that could be construed
as relevant was this guy giving dean
graziosi like a softball compliment
of oh man you were so credible and i
wish we were back in the days of
television because
back when people were on tv you could
tell that they were legit
because they were on tv they had money
to be on tv
you were credible because you had you
had money to be on tv
and now it's like you don't have to do
anything to post you don't do anything
to go
uh stand in front of somebody's jet and
be like oh yeah
dm me for success like dude do we need
to clean out
i feel bad because i'm like when i was
younger it made i could
easily identify who was credible right
like i i could say okay this dude is on
tv
what no no no oh boy
you're saying that because someone's on
tv they're credible
he's incredible now
incredible right like i i could say okay
this dude's on tv
he's incredible huh hey
have we all forgotten where don le pray
came from
the second way to make money that i
stumbled onto
was placing tiny classic classified ads
in the newspaper
have we forgotten about tom vu i know
you may be thinking
my course may be the same like everybody
else my course is
not the same like everybody else you
think that just cause someone had an
infomercial
they're credible dude this is what we're
dealing with guys
this is the big puff piece that he's
trying to cover up the ftc he's tagging
it with ftc they don't even talk about
the ftc
now why would he do that you're asking
why would dean do such a sneaky thing
because most people aren't going to see
these tags they're invisible to most
people who don't have like plugins like
this
the reason is very simple he's trying to
hide it he's trying to be the first
result when you search it
he wants to steal that little result so
you don't find out what he's been up to
because again
he doesn't address it at all here he
doesn't address us he doesn't address
the ftc
case and this is where i want to address
a real problem that i find in the
self-help industry because sure
they're all well-intentioned don't they
say that they say yeah i just want to
help you
just give me money i'll help you but
there's this forced positivity problem
that comes from all of them believing in
the secret
new thought all this kind of mumbo jumbo
about believe it and you will do it
mindset is everything
oh just have a forced positivity mindset
the problem with it
is there's nothing wrong with just a
little bit of positivity a little bit of
uh dream it you will do it
but if you take that to the extreme then
you're
incentivized nay even told taught it's
dogmatic to ignore
negativity to just hey pretend it
doesn't exist and it will go away
but the ftc doesn't go away neither does
coffee zella i don't just go away
because you pretend that i don't exist
and try to
keyword your way into search terms like
fake guru and ftc
and insider's edge and nudge they don't
go away just because you're positive
thinking and it's exactly like scott
yancey what scott did
remember this guy from our last video
about dean graziosi
he says scott yancey responds to scams
he only made this according to the
lawsuit itself
in order to hide the videos that were
exposing him as a scam
he tried to keyword his way in there and
it worked but to see
dean graziosi do this too shows you
everything you need to know these people
all have the same playbook
it's done over and over and over again
and this time i wanted to call it out
exactly as it was happening
anyway that's it and don't forget to
smash like
and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
comes along